Dolly Parton showed up to some football
game and she was dressed like a Dallas
Cowboys Cheerleader and she was wearing
her you know short shorts and her highly
cropped shirt and she did a performance
and Dolly Parton is 77 years
old and if you look at it she
looks she looks
good but I don't think anyone says Dolly
looks bad they might say she this is
disordered because Dolly Parton is 77
years old 77 old should not be dressed
like this they should not be dancing
like this and so that's disorder but
also Dolly partner is a kind of beloved
figure even conservatives love Dolly
she's not one of these radical leftist
she's sort so what what are
we
conservatives concerned with order and
propriety and etiquette and you know
gracefully aging and family values and
what are we to think about dol's
performance here's my
take Dolly
Parton is a unique case Exempted from
all rules of
etiquette and that's that I am not
denying that 77y old women should not
dress like that I am not
denying family values and proper
aesthetic sensibilities and the good the
true and the Beautiful I'm not denying
any of those
things I am not being
hypocritical I think by making an
exception for Dolly
Parton in fact I think I'm articulating
a much more conservative point which is
that exceptions prove
rules and rules have exceptions that's
the way it works this is
true in politics and philosophy and
theology modern Libs want everything to
be really clear and have really clinical
regimented rules so that you can
understand the universe in five bullet
point manifestos on the back of a napkin
nope that's not how it
works and Dolly Parton one of the other
great contributions among many that
she's made to this country she's proven
that point it is completely unacceptable
for a 77y old woman to do this is it is
wrong it is disordered it except for do
Parton do Parton she just she gets to
break the rules that's how it goes Joe
Biden has a novel theory on how war
broke out in the Middle East you know we
know the
timeline October 7th Hamas leads a Pome
against Jews in Israel takes a bunch of
hostages kills well over a thousand
civilians rapes kills pillages and burns
horrific terror attack then state of
Israel responds by bombing Gaza by in in
leading a ground Invasion into
Gaza then there's a ceasefire the ceas
fire seems to be going okay as of the
Airing of this show today Hamas
releasing some of the hostages in
exchange for a temporary ceasefire from
Israel Joe Biden says no no what that
timeline is missing is why Hamas had the
terror attack in the first place and the
reason is you see no one knows this Joe
Biden was about to bring peace to the
Middle East I cannot prove what I'm
about to say but I believe one of the
reasons why Hamas struck when they did
was they knew that I was working very
closely with the Saudis and others in
the region to bring peace to the region
by having recognition of Israel and
Israel's right to exist you may recall
when we did the G20 about a little while
ago I was able to get a resolution a a
statement passed through there saying
we're going to build a railroad from
Riad all the way through the Middle East
into into Saudi Arabia is Israel Etc and
all the way up to Europe not the not the
railroad but it would be an underground
Pipeline and then railroad pause it
right there for a second hold on before
he goes on I just want to make clear he
says he was going to build a railroad
from Riad all the way to Saudi
Arabia it isn't Riad is that how where
would that wouldn't that railroad just
be kind of like a circular it'd be he
doesn't I think he's a little well I
think we all know Joe Biden is a little
bit confused
as to how the geopolitics of the Middle
East Works keep going is there's
overwhelming interest and I think most
Arab Nations know it in coordinating
with one another to change the dynamic
in their region for longer term peace
and uh that is uh what I'm going to
continue to work on okay now people are
they're not going to believe it they're
not going to know but actually I was
about to bring peace to the Middle
East that's why people aren't going to
believe it but that's what what it
was that's the ticket yeah that's the
ticket Donald
Trump the the the last
president brought peace to the Middle
East there were no new Middle Eastern
Wars dragging the United States into
further conflict that broke out under
his watch actually what they got was a
peace deal between Saudi Arabia and
Israel actually what they got was the
Abra Accords actually what they got was
relative peace in the Middle East
actually what they got was Isis was
eliminated actually what they got was
Iran was on the its heels actually what
they got was Syria was on its heels
actually what they got was
everyone stayed real quiet and real
cautious because no one knew what Trump
was going to do was Trump the biggest
Dove ever didn't want to be involved in
any wars or was Trump the craziest war
hawk in the world who was going to drop
the Moab and assassinate top generals
left and right
he was both that's was was Donald Trump
the leader of the anti-war party an
opponent of the uni party in Washington
DC those warmongering neoconservatives
Donald Trump was going to be a new
breath of fresh air Donald Trump a
republican attacking George W bush for
starting wars in the Middle East Donald
Trump saying I want no new Wars was he
going to be that guy or was Donald Trump
gonna be the guy who appointed John
Bolton as his National Security adviser
John Bolton who has wanted to bomb Iran
since he was in the womb
who was Donald Trump he was both he was
unpredictable and his foreign policy led
to relative peace in the Middle East Joe
Biden has has led to an outbreak of War
all over the place in Eastern Europe in
the Middle East worst outbreaks of war
in either of those places in a long time
and and so how does Biden explain it
Biden I was just in New York over the
weekend Biden is like I think Family Guy
made this point once
Biden is like an Italian guy in a
hypothetical situation now listen here
you know listen if I had been there if I
had been there in the situation you're
describing oh what I would have done you
wouldn't believe what I would have done
I would have done this that and the
other thing but it's always
hypothetical what did you do it has to
be hypothetical for Biden because he's
failed it doesn't have to be
hypothetical for Trump cuz he did it yes
but uh listen here fellas I can't do a I
can't do a New York Italian Job
listen if I people aren't going to
believe it but what I would have done
what I come on Jack what I would have
what I would have done had I been able
to do the thing that I wanted to do in
the I would have brought total peace in
the Middle East listen listen Jack if my
aunt had testicles she'd have been my
uncle you know listen here pal if my
Grandma had Wheels should be a wagon all
right jack exactly exactly in the
hypothetical World in which the premises
of the left are correct then things
would work out peachy but the world is
different from the way the libs believe
the world is and that's why the
conservative policy works a lot better
man what a great clip that was now hey
hold up hold up ring that Bell subscribe
to the Michael NS YouTube channel we'll
see you next time